I'm the only one you seen it and made it
out alive
[Music]
the world is changing that will only be
conquered and the conquer service of my
life
you are a good man service my life is a
good heart
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie hopefully you
guys are still freaking out about the
Black Panther trailer the most
noticeable thing is that he actually
gets a costume changed later in the
movie in Cherie who's wearing even more
advanced vibranium technology so I'll
explain what's going on there is that
Marvel giveaway that's going on - all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
the Civil War costume is then burned
into our brains the movies already been
on Netflix for a long time so you
probably watch the billion times it's
heavily armored it looks like it has
some wakandan design all the metal
vibranium aligns in combination with the
vibranium weave suit itself you can
actually turn vibranium into almost
anything that was all Tron's Big Dig
against humanity in that movie where he
was creating the vision in combination
with that skin technology so he was able
to use vibranium to make vision that
much more advanced so it's part of the
reason why vision is able to change
himself at will
beautiful the vibranium atoms aren't
just compatible with the tissue cells
they're binding them and she never even
the most versatile substance on the
planet then they used it to make a
frisbee typical of humans I scratch the
surface to never think to look within
you're never going to think about
Captain America shield without chuckling
after that scene there was also the dig
about spider-man saying that it defies
the laws of physics which you could also
say for Black Panthers abilities during
civil war some of the CG was a little
out of control during that big chase
scene but I think they did a much better
job during the Black Panther movie so
he's wearing the civil war suit in this
opening action set piece where he's
taking down these hunters that are
looking they're trying to break into
what Conda for whatever reason it makes
sense that once he first comes back not
a whole lot has change but as things
start to spiral out of control you start
to learn more about what Condon Society
you get a much better look at what's
possible if the curtain is pulled back
on all their secrets like you're
learning as Everett Ross we as the
audience are Everett Ross because we've
never seen what Conda before you look at
the costume later in the trailer it
almost seems like it's gotten simpler a
little more aqua line a little more
form-fitting the silver necklace has
been changed to gold the eye holes have
gotten bigger and the mask looks a
little bit more like the classic comic
book costume a lot of you have asked and
this is actually a pretty good theory
that we might be looking at chachaka
when he was black panther and this is a
flashback I don't think that's the case
I think he just got a costume upgrade
and I think that Sheree is the key to
that because the actors that played her
explained why it is that she gets all
this cool technology like this is all
made from vibranium she explained in the
movie that she's a Tony Stark level
genius that's relatively young but she
just spends a lot of time experimenting
with new uses for vibranium new
technology trying to advance their
society even more if it didn't already
looked at Van Slyke you look at this
cityscape here this is the city of
tomorrow this looks like something right
out of guardians of the galaxy or a Thor
movie some intergalactic super advanced
species this is her full quote here
she's a princess of Wakanda but also she
designs all of the new technology there
she has an innovative spirit
in an innovative mind and she wants to
take Wakanda to a new place also she has
a great fashion sense I like the way she
added that better than mine so vibrant a
beautiful spirit but also so focused on
what she does so she's the person that
designs that new armor suit she also
probably helps Black Panther who's also
very smart in his own right develop new
suit technology so it's not like she's
Pepper Potts - Black Panthers Tony Stark
but just like Tony Stark makes himself
new suits all the time
Black Panther the wakandan people Cherie
also probably innovate on a regular
basis so it's like okay we have a very
special mission that we need to
accomplish here you see this big chasing
that looks like it's happening near the
casino this is all South Korea stuff
that they were filming in that part of
the world but maybe for that mission he
has some specific needs so he just
changes his suit based on that but it is
a more comic-book accurate suit so maybe
this is just going to be what the suit
looks like going forward after this this
daylight scenes probably the best look
at it where he walks up like he's
walking up to Ali vs. Foreman and kill
monger is the foreman in that situation
whatever the big challenge to his rule
is you have to imagine that what Conda
is a very big nation you get a look at
some other people that look relatively
official as if his rule is going to be
challenged there might be a coup and he
has to fight them off and win the
respect of everybody because it looks
like kill monger who is a villain is
just walking up like he's being allowed
into this arena here so that implies
that this is what his costume is going
to look like at the end of the movie and
even though Tony Stark is definitely
going to get a new Iron Man suit going
into infinity war what it sounds like
it's going to happen is this black
panther will stay in a more comic-book
accurate version of the suit and Sheree
will just continue to innovate new
technology based on his needs imagine
that this version of the suit is sort of
like the early Iron Man suits it's more
heavily armored but it's got less cool
gear on it it just built like a tank but
it doesn't have a lot of the extra cool
functions like this pulse weapon here
that probably gets built into the new
version of the suit so if you really
like black panther with like cool extra
gear on it suit the best comic book to
read is actually Ultimates - they're
like the super team of the Marvel
Universe they deal with Galactus level
problems during the
run someone's able to hack into the AI
of his suit that's right he has his own
version of Friday it doesn't talk to him
like Friday talks to Ironman it's not
going to be used for a comedy in that
way but he has to take the suit off and
show what a badass he is because he
doesn't need the suit to kick somebody's
butt so there are parts of the suit that
are practical like he actually climbs
into part of the suit and then there are
things like the helmet which work more
like Iron Man's extremis armor which is
sort of build themselves around his head
the classic version of the suit was
actually just a cloth suit it was like a
black suit that he would put on and just
walk around and kick people's asses the
more modern comics are the ones that
have added technology to that I think
just to make it seem a little bit cooler
like oh it looks like a cloth suit but
it's got all this other badass
technology because part of the idea is
if they have all this advanced
technology then things would only look
primitive when in reality they are much
more advanced than they seem that's the
whole basis of the trailer this looks
very tribal very third-world but nope
surprise surprise it is the most
advanced city on the planet so a lot of
you have also theorized that when it
comes time for infinity war then getting
into space it'll be black panther to
help them and not Ironman typically
technology in the Marvel Universe really
cool stuff comes from Ironman but now
that we've learned that Wakanda has
stuff that's way beyond that
they'll probably be the go-to and this
is called a talent fighter and like I
said in my last trailer video most of
this new big cool Wakanda stuff all
their culture their technology the way
his powers work the way he's connected
to the afterlife in the spirit realm you
can read that in the brand new black
panther run that's happening right now
leave all your requests for more black
panther videos in the comments below
there's a bunch of new spider-man Game
of Thrones and DC TV I'll try to get
through that stuff as fast as possible
though congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Tommy Canlis please
private message me so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch the
black panther trailer a billion times
and you can click here for all my other
Marvel infinity core video
thank you so much for watching let's buy
five I'll see you guys tonight
you